Egal ob schräge Diäten oder fragwürdigeFat-Burner-Pillen – nichts wirkt. Bis jetzt!
Denn eine neue Klasse von Medikamenten, die eigentlichzur Behandlung von Diabetes entwickelt wurde,
sind das erste funktionierende Abnehmedikament.Eine Revolution der Medizin. Klingt zu schön, um wahr zu sein - ist aber
wirklich Realität. In Deutschland werden sie
schon verschrieben. In etwas über einem Jahr
verlieren Menschen mit starkem Übergewicht
so um die 15 Prozent ihres Körpergewichts.
Aber bei aller Euphorie: Kann es so einfach
sein? Präsentiert sich da gerade wirklich die
Lösung für eines der größten medizinischen
Probleme unserer Zeit? Wie nachhaltig ist
der Gewichtsverlust? Und könnten
diese Medikamente noch viel mehr
Krankheiten behandeln? Genau darum
geht es heute bei Doktor Whatson.
Ein Missverständnis nervt mich bei dem Thema
wirklich immer: Übergewicht kann nämlich
verschiedene Ursachen haben, die nicht immer in
der Hand der Personen selber liegen. Der Zugang zu
Gesundheitssystemen, verschiedene Lebensumstände
und unsere Umwelt spielen genauso eine Rolle wie
genetische Faktoren. Und ja, Änderungen
im Lebensstil, also gesunde Ernährung und
ausreichend Bewegung, sind zwar ein Grundbaustein
des Gewichtsmanagements, führen aber häufig nur
zu einem schwachen Gewichtsverlust, der schwer
zu halten ist. Das liegt auch an langfristigen
Veränderungen im Körper, etwa im Sättigungszentrum
im Gehirn oder an Entzündungsprozessen.
Aber jetzt kommt der Hammer: Es gibt nun
ein Mittel, das in genau solche körperlichen
Prozesse eingreift. Bevor wir über die
Probleme davon sprechen, und ja Spoiler,
die gibt es leider: Worum geht’s eigentlich?
Lasst uns mal zurück ins Jahr 2018 gehen,
als ein Medikament namens Ozempic von
der Europäischen Arzneimittelbehörde,
EMA, zur Behandlung von Typ-II-Diabetes zugelassen
wird. Es geht also erstmal nur um Diabetiker: Der
Wirkstoff dieses Medikaments – Semaglutid – hilft
dabei, den Blutzucker zu regulieren, indem er sich
genauso verhält, wie eine Form des körpereigenen
Darmhormons Inkretin. Das nennt man GLP-1. Der
Wirkstoff ist dem GLP-1 so ähnlich, dass er an den
dafür vorgesehenen Rezeptor bindet. Deswegen nennt
man diese Medikamente auch GLP-1-Analoga oder
Inkretin-Mimetika – also “Inkretin-Nachmacher”.
Bei gesunden Personen wird GLP-1 vor allem
nach dem Essen ausgeschüttet und stimuliert
unter anderem die Abgabe von Insulin, wodurch
dann der Blutzuckerspiegel sinkt. Nice. Ist
aber nicht genug GLP-1 vorhanden, wird
dieser natürliche Regulierungsprozess
gestört. Wirkstoffe wie Semaglutid, die so tun als
wären sie GLP-1, können Diabetikern also helfen.
Diese Nachmacher können aber noch mehr.
Denn noch während die klinischen Studien
mit Diabetikern liefen, wurde klar, dass sie
nicht nur Ihren Blutzucker senken können,
sondern nebenher auch noch ihr Gewicht.
Die Inkretin-Mimetika binden nämlich
nicht nur an die Rezeptoren im Darm,
sondern auch im Gehirn - im Hypothalamus. So
aktivieren sie bestimmte Neuronen - äh diese
hier - dadurch sinkt das Hungergefühl, während
das Sättigungsgefühl steigt. Kurz gesagt:
Sie verringern den Appetit und
das Verlangen nach fettigen,
energiereichen Lebensmitteln und setzen damit
genau da an, wo viele Abnehmversuche scheitern.
Seitdem haben die Unternehmen hinter
den Medikamenten einige Studien mit
stark übergewichtigen Menschen ohne Diabetes
durchgeführt. Und das hat funktioniert - wenn
auch eher so semi gut. Ein Wirkstoff namens
Liraglutid konnte zum Beispiel über 56 Wochen
einen durchschnittlichen Gewichtsverlust von etwa
8 Prozent bewirken, immerhin über 5 Prozentpunkte
mehr als ein Placebo. Umgehauen hat das zwar
keinen so wirklich, aber basierend auf Liraglutid
wurde ein Wirkstoff entwickelt, der nicht so
schnell abgebaut wird und länger im Körper bleibt.
Ja und dieser Wirkstoff - Semaglutid - hat
dann so richtig gut funktioniert. So gut,
dass er nicht nur unter Experten
als absoluter Gamechanger gilt,
sondern auch, dass Social Media komplett
eskaliert - aber dazu gleich mehr.
Die Experten beziehen sich mit dem Gamechanger
vor allem auf eine Studie von 2021.Mi Darin wurde
untersucht, wie gut Semaglutid – in Kombination
mit einer Ernährungsumstellung und ausreichend
Bewegung, stark übergewichtigen Personen beim
Abnehmen hilft. In knapp 15 Monaten konnten
die Teilnehmer ihr Körpergewicht
durchschnittlich um 14,9 Prozent
reduzieren. In der Placebogruppe waren es
gerade mal über 2,4 Prozent . Semaglutid
wirkt also und könnte das Leben von hunderten
Millionen von Menschen nachhaltig verändern.
Wie bei jedem Medikament gibt es natürlich auch
Nebenwirkungen. Am häufigsten treten Übelkeit
und Verdauungsprobleme auf – das hält sich durch
eine langsame Dosissteigerung aber in Grenzen.
Insgesamt aber überwiegt der Nutzen gegenüber dem
Risiko. Die EMA hat Semaglutid deswegen unter dem
Handelsnamen Wegovy schon zur Behandlung von
Übergewicht zugelassen. Voraussetzung ist ein
BMI von über 30 oder von 27, wenn gewichtsbedingte
Begleiterkankungen, wie Bluthochdruck, vorliegen.
Wenn ihr mehr über den BMI erfahren wollt und
wieso er trotz starker Kritik in der Medizin
verwendet wird, könnt ihr euch dieses Video
dazu anschauen. Wegovy ist mittlerweile sogar
schon ab 12 Jahren zugelassen. Die Anwendung
ist einfach: einmal wöchentlich eine Spritze,
die funktioniert wie diese EPI-Pens, die ihr
vielleicht von Allergikern kennt. Für Diabetiker
gibt es Semaglutid auch in Tablettenform, für
Übergewicht ist das aber noch nicht zugelassen.
Ok. Das klingt… fast perfekt, oder?
Verlässlich Abnehmen ohne sich die
ganzen Gedanken um das eigene Essen zu
machen. Das ist wahrscheinlich der Traum
von Millionen von Menschen allein in Deutschland.
Bevor ihr jetzt direkt in die nächste
Arztpraxis sprintet - STOPP! Denn ihr
werdet Wegovy wahrscheinlich nicht bekommen.
Denn Semaglutid ist gerade Mangelware,
der Hersteller Novo Nordisk hat schon Probleme bei
der Produktion für Diabetiker hinterherzukommen.
Wir haben mal nachgefragt und die Firma hat uns
gesagt, dass die Produktion zwar schon ausgebaut
wurde, mit einer weltweit so starken Nachfrage
habe man aber einfach nicht gerechnet. Tja,
wer hätte gedacht, dass sich Leute für
das erste, verlässlich funktionierende
Abnehm-Medikament interessieren? Novo Nordisk
anscheinend nicht. Egal, zurück zum Thema.
Denn obwohl Wegovy bis vor kurzem in vielen
Ländern noch gar nicht erhältlich war , wurde
Semaglutid während der ganzen Zeit schon zum
Abnehmen verschrieben - und zwar in Form von
Ozempic. In Ozempic und Wegovy steckt der gleiche
Wirkstoff – Wegovy enthält nur viel mehr davon. Um
den GLP-1-Rezeptor im Gehirn anzusprechen, braucht
es nämlich etwa doppelt so viel Semaglutid,
wie für die Diabetesbehandlung nötig. Statt
Wegovy können Ärzte also auch Ozempic bei
Übergewicht verschreiben. Das ist dann zwar
nicht die optimale Dosis - aber es funktioniert.
Und zwar so gut, dass das Internet voll von
Erfolgsstories ist. Der Hashtag Ozempic hat
allein auf Tiktok etwa 1.2 B Aufrufe?
Billionen? Billionen klingt etwas viel,
wahrscheinlich in Übersetzungsfehler von TikTok,
denn Billion ist im Deutschen Milliarden. Egal!
Und wenn dann noch Promis wie Elon Musk twittern,
wie toll sie abgenommen haben, schafft das immer
mehr Aufmerksamkeit und immer mehr Menschen, die
ihre Ärzte aktiv um die Abnehmspritzen bitten.
Die nehmen dann damit ab, berichten dann auch
wieder online und in den Medien darüber… und
so weiter und so fort… Es ist ein Teufelskreis,
der maßgeblich zu den Lieferengpässen beiträgt.
Die Nutzung außerhalb der ursprünglichen
Zulassung nennt man Off-Label Use. Zahlen dazu
liegen uns leider nicht vor, aber wir wissen,
dass verglichen zum letzten Frühjahr 74% mehr
Ozempic-Spritzen verkauft wurden, als noch 2022.
Die Diabetesfälle in Deutschland steigen zwar seit
Jahren an – so stark aber bei weitem nicht.
Und daraus ergibt sich ein richtiges Problem,
denn der Off-Label-Einsatz gefährdet
aktuell die Versorgung von Patienten
mit Diabetes Typ 2 . Und die stehen in der
Apotheke dann teilweise vor leeren Regalen.
Das haben uns einige unserer Zuschauer und
Ärzte in Hintergrundgesprächen bestätigt.
Von dem Off-Label-Use von Ozempic wird
deswegen von zuständigen Behörden, dem
Hersteller und vielen anderen Experten abgeraten
und dieser sollte sogar verhindert werden.
Daraus ergibt sich ein ethischer Konflikt. Wer
ist eher berechtigt, ein Medikament zu bekommen,
wenn es gerade nicht genug davon gibt? Denn
auch Patienten mit starkem Übergewicht und
Begleiterkrankungen, die von der Gewichtsreduktion
profitieren würden, haben ja ein Recht auf
Therapie. Adipositas ist eine chronische
Erkrankung und keine persönliche Entscheidung.
Und - das muss ich klar betonen: eine Therapie
mit Semaglutid richtet sich nicht an Leute,
die ein paar Kilo loswerden wollen. Es geht um
Menschen, die bereits seit Jahren versuchen,
Gewicht zu verlieren, das ihre Gesundheit
signifikant beeinträchtigt. Und selbst
wenn wir irgendwann in Semaglutid schwimmen
sollten, bleibt es höchstwahrscheinlich ein
Medikament für stark übergewichtige
Menschen und kein Lifestyle-Produkt.
Und selbst wenn: Das Medikament alleine
reicht nicht. Die Patienten müssen trotzdem
ihre Ernährung umstellen und sich ausreichend
bewegen - und auch mit möglichen Nebenwirkungen
zurechtkommen. Für einen nachhaltigen
Gewichtsverlust wird auch zu einer
Verhaltenstherapie geraten. Denn wer die Spritzen
irgendwann absetzt, bei dem kehrt sofort der
Hunger von früher zurück. Erste Studien zeigen,
dass viele der Patienten direkt wieder zunehmen.
Ein Punkt, der mir noch wichtig ist, ist
die Kostenfrage. Denn das Zeug ist richtig
teuer. In den USA liegt der Listenpreis für eine
Monatsration Wegovy bei umgerechnet um die 1.230
Euro. Also fast 15 Tausend Euro im Jahr! Und
auch in Deutschland ist das ganze nicht gerade
billig. Das ist problematisch. Denn selbst wenn
Wegovy bald zuverlässig erhältlich ist, darf es
nicht von der gesetzlichen Krankenkasse übernommen
werden. Laut Sozialgesetzbuch sind Arzneimittel,
mit denen vordergründig eine Erhöhung
der Lebensqualität bezweckt wird, von der
Versorgungspflicht ausgeschlossen. Ergo: die Kasse
zahlt nicht. Darunter fallen auch Medikamente zur
Zügelung des Appetits und Reduzierung des
Körpergewichts, wie Wegovy. Das steht im
Widerspruch dazu, dass Adipositas nicht nur von
den Fachgesellschaften, sondern auch vom Bundestag
als Krankheit anerkannt ist. Die Patienten
müssen also selbst für die Therapiekosten
ihrer anerkannten Krankheit aufkommen, was
ich persönlich sozial extrem ungerecht finde.
Dazu kommt, dass sich der gesellschaftliche Druck
abzunehmen noch weiter erhöhen könnte. Das
ist nicht nur problematisch für Menschen,
die sich eine Therapie nicht leisten können oder
nicht dafür geeignet sind, sondern auch für die,
die die Medikamente einfach nicht wollen - weil
sie gesund und glücklich mit ihrem Gewicht sind.
Da Wegovy seit kurzem auch in Deutschland
erhältlich ist, sollte sich jetzt immerhin
das Problem mit dem Off-Label-Use einstellen.
Die Lieferprobleme bleiben aber bestehen,
bis es genügend Produktionskapazität
gibt - daran wird gearbeitet. Also:
alles eine Frage der Zeit, die verglichen
mit den 20 Jahren, in denen auf so ein
Medikament hingearbeitet wurde, eher kurz
ist. Und: Semaglutid ist erst der Anfang.
Es gibt bereits einen weiteren Wirkstoff,
Tirzepatid, der nicht mehr nur an den Rezeptor
für GLP-1, sondern auch an den für GIP bindet.
Diese duale Wirkweise funktioniert bei Personen
ohne Diabetes sogar noch besser als Semaglutid.
Und auch bei stark übergewichtigen Diabetikern,
die wegen ihrer Erkrankung oft besonders mit
dem Abnehmen kämpfen, ist Tirzepatid überlegen.
Für Adipositas läuft in den USA bereits
ein beschleunigtes Zulassungsverfahren.
Für Typ-II-Diabetes ist es schon zugelassen
und surprise - zeitweise auch von weltweiten
Lieferengpässen betroffen. Gerade wird
sogar noch ein Tri-Agonist getestet,
der einen dritten Rezeptor anspricht und
wahrscheinlich noch besser funktioniert.
Und die Studien in diesem Gebiet überschlagen
sich gerade. Während die Wirkstoffe immer besser
werden, erschließen sich weitere Einsatzgebiete
- die Fachwelt wartet gebannt auf die Ergebnisse
einer Studie, die die Wirksamkeit bei
Herzerkrankungen und Schlaganfällen
bestätigen soll, auf die es starke Hinweise gibt.
Und weil GLP-1 Teil des Belohnungssystems ist,
könnten sogar Menschen profitieren, die mit
dem Rauchen aufhören wollen - auch das wird
gerade getestet. Wer weiß, vielleicht werden wir
in der Zukunft alle zu perfekten Menschen, die
super toll aussehen und keine Laster haben?! Wir
werden von diesen Medikamenten also definitiv noch
mehr hören - unsere Redaktion bleibt auf jeden
Fall dran. Ihr bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.